I don't know much about and because I
just asked a question
mm-hmm can't you just split up Jerusalem
50/50 it is already split up 50/50 I
don't know if it's 50/50 well for
example though it is say that which is
the really the part that everyone's
fighting over woman I don't want to say
that but everybody's really obsessed
with the old city which is the biblical
part of the city and that is cut up into
perfect quarters from after World War
two with like the Christians the Jews
the Muslims and there's another group
that I'm like the Jenna nights are some
weird one that nobody really got that
so that's what so they it is split up
like yeah I grew uh East Jerusalem you
don't that's that's air that's all
Arabic there's a lot there's a lot of
places where you see everyone coexisting
by step the problem is the extremes on
both sides the Orthodox Jewish people
cause trouble yeah and the terror is
terrorist yeah well you know who do all
the terror attacks on the other side
they caused the trouble
yeah but I feel like if you ask most
people especially my age they'll be like
just do whatever it takes just don't
[ __ ] your ear-splitter do the two [ __ ]
two-state solution do whatever it takes
I mean there was a cab driver in Beirut
who had a [ __ ] tattoo of Hitler on
his stomach okay so I have to say it was
walking among the Arab world i entice
Emmet ISM is very real
yeah but I'm not gonna say if it's
warranted I don't know they [ __ ]
always hated the Jews they always I
don't I don't know but like we're not
gonna solve the problem yeah we're not
solving that right now but uh but you
know well it surprised me
it's good to just to kind of talk about
it yes it is um it's it remains to be
one of the just dilemmas of the world
then we have to deal with and it may
never be resolved it doesn't sound like
it will ever be resolved thank you know
the closest we ever got we had this uh
she was named the Israeli Prime Minister
there one Oh God yeah yeah Robin Robin
was that his name there was this guy he
was really close to achieving peace with
the palace
and get and who killed him a Jewish guy
a fundamental Jew who thought [ __ ] these
guys let's not make peace and he took
them out it's not as if they're making
money or there's no money tied to it it
really is you know strictly about God
probably just get the religion everyone
the Palestinians are definitely being
[ __ ] by everybody like they that's
what got to be one of the worst places
to live in the whole world
he's Gaza and and the thing about gods
is that like Egypt's got the border
closed Israel's got the border closed
and Israel despite having given up like
autonomy and whatever they still control
they still control yeah they regularly
go in there and kill terrorists they
control the water and the power and all
this [ __ ] Wow
so is there McDonald's there in Gaza
possibly I think there might be bugs
like if I was there and I go to a
Starbuck you might this some of the
images I've seen are strikingly
civilized Wow but it's still [ __ ] cuz
you've got like [ __ ] how many people
there I don't know the exact number but
it's one it's the most dense place in
the world it's just packed
unemployment's like 50 percent but a lot
of drugs all right the regular people
there are I mean everyone feels bad for
them even on you know the Jewish side oh
yeah they're just what can you do they
talk about Hamas is like yeah there's
videos of like people celebrating a
wedding in Gaza and then Hamas rolls up
and is like no celebrating and [ __ ]
shut like there Hamas is insane it's a
and then people try to give money to
Gaza the government power some moss and
they take the money and they used to
build weapons so it's like your father
they're really [ __ ] on on all sides
yeah yeah it's just one of those sad
things that you just you know like you
know I think about it sometimes and I
just go there is no solution that makes
me even sad or really to be honest with
you what do we do I mean I don't know
where no I live that I did that
I think I brought this conversation into
this error I'm fully a thousand percent
interest yeah I part of the reason I
left is because I was like this is too
much like it's so like just having just
living there and being on YouTube it's
just so polarizing to people yeah like
what honestly when we started doing
YouTube we hid the fact that we were in
Israel no because we just were like we
didn't want OSAC started Age 3 in Israel
yeah no the podcast no no has been
around for like a year maybe like five
years Wow what kind of videos would you
make is it like like a podcast or was it
sketches and stuff sketches comedy like
that oh wow
so we have like I remember we would like
cover Hebrew writing I feel like that
yeah yeah and we're just like I don't
want people just cuz we don't want to
necessarily be don't want to be about
that about that yeah yeah yeah to you
know not be boxed in to it's like oh
your support is really yeah yeah yeah
cuz it's so complicated to a lot of
people I have a good friend who is
Lebanese and to him the simple even the
simple fact that I went to Israel to
live with my wife is enough to make for
him to have disassociated with me Wow
and it's like dude I'm not going there
for political reason I'm literally going
there to be with my wife because I don't
have an option
yeah that to him is like wow that's have
enough to disassociate with me like I am
I'm a coward bro I'm not [ __ ] yeah
yeah he also couldn't come to a wedding
because he was like my closest friend
and he was in Lebanon which is just you
know so close to yeah oh you guys got
married in Israel yes Wow yeah well we
had to yeah for the Greek for that great
card it's so funny because it's like you
know aside from like oh the religious
stuff and you know whatever I'm Korean
she's Filipino what do you he's a you
grew up in a really weird Christian
religion what was it called Adventist 7
what is that that's a weird one right no
weird nah no weird like sexual stuff
god bless do you dance now are you still
far you're still religious dude do you
enjoy dancing now more than like most
yeah reggae group it with the two right
yeah 78 Oh Ventus god bless you guys are
good old boys right where you from boy
but he listened like look listen to this
is incredible yes we got these freaks
right we got the freak we got we know
you got right we're all from different
parts of everywhere right now with
different ideologies and if we don't
think about that and we're just around
each other and we're just talking we're
just just regular human being yeah yeah
it's really frustrating because I like
the way I always thought about his like
I'm just I was just born here yeah I
don't care like I don't know the history
and I don't care well all these people
here yeah you know now I have to choose
sides and I have two guys and I'm saying
that's why the reason I left is cause
like I'm like this isn't my fight and
ela I think since before she knew
thought it wasn't her fight she never
belong there and it's like I don't
really want to be involved in in this
because when you live in Israel you
start to learn things or maybe you're I
don't know if it's a brainwashing thing
or you're just you're with the club
right you're willing that tribe yeah so
it gets through to you yeah before I
went to Israel I was very
pro-palestinian
because I went to very liberal college
went to UC Santa Cruz and there it's
like they literally have protests on the
campus of like Israeli show soldiers
executing Palestinians and I was like
okay yeah that's totally what it is but
when you go there and then you learn
because you spend time with that tribe
and you understand all their talking
points and [ __ ] and he's it's just so
confusing dude yeah I mean I got even by
go visiting doing this tourist thing I
posted a couple of photos because that
was a part of the deal and the backlash
of me just go away right was insane yeah
right it's propaganda I can't believe
you took chose sides and I just wanted
to have free
trip to the dead sea of that but you're
I wasn't I float on the on the sea
without any [ __ ] effort so heavily
salting it slow but it's so I hate that
because it's so counterproductive it's
like how are we gonna make progress if
you're telling people you can't even go
there and talk to them because you go
there and you talk to them you learn
about them you learn what you know
what's interesting perspective
yeah like what am I just supposed to
shut out that whole part and just take
your word for it
yeah like what the [ __ ] do you know yeah
it's crazy
it really is crazy but but we're here
yeah Neela's brothers Israeli and he
said to it's just the other day he's
like I meet Palestinians here all the
[ __ ] time and we love each other we
always get along here yeah it's just
over there that we all hate each other
it's amazing I have a friend I have
several friends there are Muslim and it
never comes up I never talk about it you
don't even think about it yeah and
they're just loving people I know so
many Jewish people they're just the most
nicest loving people
mm-hmm and it's like and then when you
hear about this conflict it just boggles
the [ __ ] mind and I'm just you know
I'm not a part of it I'm just observing
but I'm a part of humanity in a part of
the human race
mhm and I just want you know what Rodney
King said I forgot what he said you may
remember the spirit I forgot what he
sounded about when you said something
about people a people great people
people people are great and I love the
people right if we just defined it by
what that guy's that black I said
remember him
[Music]